le jeu de l'amour et du hasard de
marivaux c'est tout à fait pour la
comédie française est mise en scène par
un très grand metteur en scène jacques
ronnie avec sonia vollereaux jean
philippe puymartin alors on ne raconte
pas le voit là bas raconte à la voile à
se marrer à l'otan alors c'est un jeune
premier une jeune première une jeune
fille un jeune homme
ils se connaissent pas mais on veut les
mariés et voudrait faire connaissance
autrement plus intimement ils se
déguisent avec leurs suivants leurs
servantes et leurs serviteurs et bien
voilà ça c'est le jeu de l'amour et du
hasard vu par point de vue images du
monde alors maintenant regardez un
extrait de la pièce c'est très beau et
puis marie vous vous savez ça n'a l'air
de rien on dit du marivaudage mais en
réalité c'est je crois le plus grand
écrivain révolutionnaire oui regardez
bien ce qui se dit derrière ces échanges
galant c'est très audacieux pour
l'époque et ça l'est encore aujourd'hui
regardez bien messieurs on commence non
va bien je plais déjà la soubrette put
alors que tu es et pourquoi dans mon
entrée était si gentil tu m'avais tant
promis de laisser la façon dont nous
parlait sopi trivial je t'avais donné de
si bonnes aux instructions je ne t'avais
recommandé que d'être sérieux pas tu
vois bien que je suis en étourdi demande
être fier voilà je ferai encore mieux
dans les suites et puisque le sérieux
n'est pas suffisant je donnerais tu es
l'homme comme je pleurais s'il le faut
qui dit
je ne sais plus où j'en suis cette
aventure si mes tours 10 que faut-il que
je fasse est la fille n'est pas
puissante crois mon cher monsieur je
vous demande il pardonne donc nous avons
fait attendre m ce n'est que de cet
instant que japon que vous êtes ici je
suis pardon c'est beaucoup trop une
danse aucun canton n'a fait qu'une faute
au surplus
[Musique]
et bien que me veux tu lisais tiens à
vous entretenir un moment de quoi
s'agit-il de vous dire les termes sont
les choses parce qu'il est important que
vous en soyez éclaircies afin de vous
n'ayez pointe à vous plaindre de moi
saisi dans le but un sérieux oui très
sérieux vous avez vous ressenti au
déguisement de mademoiselle sylvia moi
même je les trouvais d'abord sans
conséquence mais je me suis trompé et
fait de telles conséquences est il donc
messieurs on a de la peine à se nouer
soi même mais malgré toutes les règles
et à la modestie
il faut pourtant que je vous dise ces
météores ce qui arrive votre prétendu
n'aura plus le coeur à donner à
mademoiselle votre fille
il est temps pour seul éclat seul arrêt
car un jour plus tard je n'en répond
plus mais que me demandez vous dites moi
un petit brin cours mais vous tenez je
vous ai moi fait l'écho
répétez princesse qu'elle un social eh
bien monsieur
eh bien madame je me convenir me confond
j'ai peur d'encourir les sens
[Musique]